hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new iphone 12 pro max it's been a
long wait
and today we are going to put it up head
to head against its biggest competitor
by far
the galaxy note 20 ultra now you guys
probably know
that i love the note 20 ultra it is
better than the 11 pro max
awesome phone and we're gonna find out
did apple do enough
with the new iphone to make it compete
let's start out with the exteriors and i
want to talk about
comfort now believe it or not the 12 pro
max is actually more comfortable to hold
in the hand
than the 11 pro max even though it's
slightly bigger because of the squared
off edges
now comparing it to the note 20 ultra
it really is a hit or miss in some ways
the note 20 is more comfortable the
rounded edges here
um there they make it feel slimmer in
the hand it doesn't feel as
thick even though it's actually thicker
but this little square
edge at the bottom kind of digs into
your
palm whereas the iphone it has these
nice
rounded edges over here and it just fits
really nicely in the hand
let's go ahead and stack these side by
side and you can see that the iphone is
actually
slightly wider than the samsung but the
note 20 is actually slightly taller
because it has a 6.9 inch display
with a wider aspect ratio and then if we
take a look at the camera bump so we
have a pretty big
difference apple has this etched glass
design
and it's completely square with three
separate lenses inside of it where
samsung has just gone from one
massive rectangular slate of course
the samsung sticks out quite a bit more
apple actually has a three-tier system
like a pyramid
we have the glass first then we have the
rings the gold ones
and then we have the lenses that stick
out even more it seems like they're
trying to hide the
the little camera bump trying to make it
smaller where
samsung is just embracing it now you may
also notice a couple other
differences here in the actual camera
modules and i'm going to talk about that
in a little bit
when we talk about cameras you also
probably noticed the difference in
color this year the gold on the iphone
12 pro max for the gold model looks more
like gold
but the back looks less like gold it
almost looks whitish especially
next to the bronze on the note 20. now i
definitely would have to say that
i wish i could have this bronze on the
back of the iphone i really like that
deep nice color one thing i don't like
is that we still have to have this
little
imei note code and manufacturing on
there i love the clean look of the
iphone
looking at the bottom the note uses usb
type c compared to lightning on the
iphone
i do wish the iphone would use usb type
c
and you'll also notice that we have the
s pen on
the note which we're going to talk about
in just a little bit
flipping over to the sides this is a
massive difference in design
the note goes for this tiny slim frame
because all this glass is curved
whereas the iphone has this massive
frame and the iphone just has
one button for the screen on the right
side and it is huge it's very clicky it
feels really great
the note actually has the volume buttons
on the same side
which i do like but you have to reach
all the way up you have to
shift your hand to be able to reach them
the iphone has the volume buttons on the
left hand side
and also a mute switch which i do really
like whereas the note is absolutely
clean on the left
overall i'm surprised to say that the
iphone both feels
nicer in the hand a little bit more
premium and
more comfortable at the same time and i
wasn't expecting that
and comparing the fronts you guys see
there's a big difference
in bezels and camera cutouts and notches
so the bezel on the note 20 is extremely
small because that glass is curved over
the edge
it hides the bezel makes it almost
disappear
whereas in the iphone it's completely
flat no hiding it
so you see it much more now it is
completely even all around which is nice
instead of having
a different forehead and chin and sides
and then of course we have that notch
which does stick out a lot compared to
that cutout
i have to say that the note 20 does look
more futuristic because those bezels are
so slim
and we don't have the notch but because
the glass
is curved it's a lot more prone to
shattering if you drop it
the iphone's flat glass in the frame is
more protective and with that
apple is using the new ceramic shield
glass
that is a lot stronger in terms of drop
protection the other thing i noticed is
the off
axis shift the note 20 is using older
oled technologies so when you look from
the side
even slightly it turns blue and it loses
more brightness than the iphone
and the new 12s they're the first oled
screens
that don't shift blue when you're
looking from the side
and now let's compare the brightness i'm
going to max both of these out
and i do have them set to manual
brightness
and here you guys can see the difference
the iphone is
much brighter it's at about 900 nits
compared to maybe about 600 or 500 on
the note 20
and that is just because samsung limits
the brightness in manual mode
if we were to go outside in a very sunny
day they would look identical as they
have in the past
you just don't have the extra option to
boost it yourself we also have a
difference in screen
reflectivity the note 20 doesn't have as
good of
coatings so it's a little bit more
reflective
and along with that because of the
rounded curved edges
you get a lot more reflections there as
well now i want to point something out
right now while i have a chance
i love the always on display on the
samsung i don't know why apple is still
not giving us that option
just to be able to glance over and see
your notifications the time it's really
nice
you'll also be able to notice this
little fingerprint here of course the
note 20 ultra has an
under display fingerprint sensor and
that one is ultrasonic and it works
really well
most of the time we're seeing a little
bit of lag there
overall it's way better than when these
first came out back then
face id was way better now if you're
wearing a mask it's really nice to have
that
in other cases face id is more
convenient for example
if you have an application open and it
wants to authenticate you don't have to
do anything it'll just be automatic you
don't have to move
your finger or shift your hand so in
general i do prefer
face id a little bit more and the other
difference in displays
is the fact that with the note 20 you
can switch it to 120
hertz now if you do that you lower the
screen
uh resolution it goes down to a 1080p
screen and with that you do get much
smoother motion so here's the side by
side for you guys we're gonna shoot 4k
120 fps slow motion so you guys can see
the differences
the note 20 is definitely a lot smoother
but with that said when i did use the
note 20
i would switch it to the high res mode
because text just didn't look as crisp
there's a little bit of blurriness
and i just like the higher resolution i
i will say
i do wish that the iphone the next one
comes with that i'm pretty sure they're
going to add it
as long as they don't make you drop the
resolution and also compare the quality
of
hdr video since both of these have
bright displays
one interesting difference is that the
iphone can now play back 4k
video even the iphone se whereas
the note is limited to 1440p and then if
you have it in the 120 hertz mode
you're actually limited to 1080p so i
love being able to oversample
i gotta be honest and say wow the
iphone's hdr
really stands out and that's interesting
because the previous iphones were always
beaten out by the samsungs
the highlights just look so much
brighter they pop
so much more we adjusted the top camera
so we're not blowing those
out you guys can see the difference
there as far as the contrast the iphone
looks better as well
it has a little bit more color and the
image is sharper as well because we're
streaming 4k
compared to 1440p and then of course
like i said 120 hertz you can always
do 1080. now if we stretch these out you
will see that the note 20
is a lot more immersive the edges are
square which fits video better and we
have a small hole punch
instead of that large notch that is
taking you know a chunk
out of that screen there with that said
the note 20 still has really good hdr
better than most phones
but it can't compete with the new oled
screen in the iphone
and with that let's compare the speakers
now i'm excited for this comparison
apple didn't say that the iphone 12s are
any better but they definitely
are and the note 20 is the best sounding
smartphone in terms of speakers i have
ever heard so go ahead and put on your
best pair of headphones or maybe if you
just have one pair the only pair you
have
and let's take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and this was
a very interesting one first off i do
want to say that we did have dolby atmos
turned on
on the note 20 and i'm surprised to see
that the iphone does sound
just as loud now we also use the decibel
meter on my apple watch and the iphone
actually peaked one decibel louder
both were very loud and that is actually
because
the high frequencies are much more
prominent
they are sharper they're a little more
clear
whereas the note the mids are actually
the loudest point
the mids are louder than on the iphone
now to be honest
i would prefer something right in the
middle in some cases like with this song
the vocal sound
excellent on the iphone for some other
type of audio some podcasts
the heist could be a little bit too much
where the opposite goes
for the note 20. now another area where
the iphone does win at
is the bass it definitely has a deeper
more bassy sound so can i say that the
iphone
smokes the note no but apple definitely
made some big improvements
and i wonder why they didn't mention it
and now let's get into performance and
we're going to start out by
testing out the 5g speeds finally
apple is in the modern world with 5g
now in our city we just have sub 6 we
don't have mid band or millimeter wave
but we are going to compare him now
if one very interesting thing is that
the note right now is showing full
bars and we're inside of a concrete
building the iphone is showing only two
out of four bars
and before i hit start i want to say
that these have the same exact
snapdragon x55 modem
so that didn't change at all and that is
the best modem on the market
we're connected to the same server let's
go ahead and start the test
and i know some people say don't run
them both at the same time
but there's thousands of people
connected to the same tower using it
right now
and this is interesting very interesting
even though the note 20 shows five bars
compared to now just
one bar on the iphone look at that the
iphone got
more than twice the speed that
is very weird now as far as the upload
they are
practically identical right now so
that's weird that the iphone is faster
even though it has less bars maybe the
antennas are better
now i actually went outside right now
and i tested
both without being in a concrete
building and for some reason the iphone
it was only connecting to lte not 5g
but the download speed was actually a
good amount faster and then when we
switched to
upload as you know 5g uploading is much
faster and so the speed difference there
is pretty big
and now as soon as i come inside it's
back to 5g that's very odd
maybe it chose lte because it was faster
for download outside
now the last difference is that the new
iphones they have this
a cutout for the millimeter wave antenna
whereas the note 20 doesn't have it
anywhere so
based on these results it might seem
like the iphone might have better
antennas and now let's compare the cpu
and graphics performance i'm going to go
ahead and run
the cpu benchmark you guys may have seen
that
the note 20 has a massive 12 gigs of
ram compared to the iphone 12 pro max is
six gigs of ram
now that's a huge difference but in the
real world there actually isn't much
difference anymore the previous iphones
they did struggle with ram
the camera used a lot so some background
apps would shut down
and thankfully apple responded gave us
six gigs of ram and now in phone buffs
uh speed test the iphone kept every
single app
open and he said that was the first time
he's ever seen it so
as far as ram no issues anymore we have
our results here and
wow that is a big difference we have 981
compared to 1604 this 1604 is beating
out
all computers out there it's incredible
so
that is a 65 difference in single core
score
now as far as multi-core score we have a
35
difference still pretty dang big and the
reason why the multi-core isn't as big
of a difference is because
the snapdragon 865 plus in here is an
eight core processor
apple's a14 bionic is only a six core
processor now one thing this score
doesn't completely quantify
is machine learning both of these have
machine learning cores
but the a14 doubled the machine learning
cores and made each core faster
so if we take a look the iphone is
almost twice
as fast in machine learning you look at
speech recognition
all of that is so much better on the a14
bionic and now let's compare the
graphics performance
we're using gfx bench we're running the
aztec ruins 1440p
off screen to make sure it's completely
fair that doesn't care about the
screen resolutions let's get started and
here are the
results wow that is a big difference and
this is
the latest apps and we're trying to make
this as fair as possible
the a14 graphics chip is incredible we
got 38.2 frames per second
whereas with the note 20 ultra we got 23
frames per second so
um the iphone is actually more than 65
percent
higher frame rate now i do have to say
that if you're somebody who's gaming
right now
both these phones are gonna be very
similar they can handle the latest games
the difference comes in two years from
now three years from now where the
iphone is still gonna be
great with the latest games whereas the
note 20 is gonna start to struggle
and now let's talk about battery life
the note 20 ultra has a 4500 milliamp
hour battery whereas the iphone is now
at 3600 so the iphone actually got
smaller
now thankfully the a14 is more optimized
as long as you're not gaming
and in the real world the battery life
difference is about an hour to an hour
and a half
with the samsung if you're not using the
120
hertz so iphone did actually get worse
and the note is actually the king now
and with that we have a difference in
chargers the note 20 comes with a 25
watt charger
it could charge up in just over an hour
whereas the iphone
doesn't come with a charger at all you
have to buy one of apple's 20 watt
chargers or a third-party one
and with that you can also buy a magsafe
charger
and that does promise 15 watt peak
charging but that's only
peak the samsung can also do 15 watt
wireless charging but i feel like it
keeps up the wattage higher
than the iphone now along with that with
the max
if you have a bunch of different
accessories there's car mounts coming
out a bunch of stuff
and we also have things like wallets so
this can definitely be useful and i
am using this wallet and i'm liking it
and the note
obviously has its own killer feature and
that is the
s pen now i have to say i'm not a very
big fan
of the s pen but i don't have anything
against it i just don't really use it i
try to make myself use it for a couple
days and then i just end up going back
to the touchscreen
but for some people the s pen is
definitely a really
nice feature especially if you like to
draw take notes stuff like that
and now let's talk about the cameras
both of these have
excellent cameras but we do have some
differences now
on the back the samsung have this has
this massive camera bump
that's because it has that crazy optical
telescopic
zoom camera you're going to get some
great zoom photos
and then it also has a 108 megapixel
camera with an even larger sensor than
the new 12
pro max now i have to be honest if we
start taking photos right now this video
is going to be 10 minutes
longer and we are going to be doing an
unbiased camera comparison taking a look
at
a ton of different things and putting
these really head to head
so make sure you guys are subscribed so
you guys catch that that's going to be
coming out on monday
you don't want to miss it and now let's
talk about the prices
and my final verdict the iphone doesn't
come with that charging brick but it
also doesn't cost
thirteen hundred dollars it's two
hundred dollars less expensive than the
note 20 ultra at
1100 now as far as the storage both come
with 128 gigabytes of storage
but the samsung does offer a micro sd
card slot which means
you can expand it in the future and for
a lot less money
with iphone it costs more and you have
to do it when you buy it and finally
which one of these phones should you buy
one huge difference we haven't mentioned
yet
is the fact that we have android
compared to ios a lot of people like ios
if you use macbooks you have ipads
if you want to use an apple watch it is
really nice to have and
if you want more customization a lot
more options you want 120 hertz right
now
the android is really nice of course if
you want
really good zoom photos the note 20 is
also good
but a lot of the advantages such as the
nice screen great speakers
hdr um that part is now gone or the
iphone
at least is very competitive now so you
guys let us know which one of these
phones do you think
is the true flagship which one is the
king
down in the comments section below make
sure you guys click that circle above to
subscribe
help us reach 500 000 before the end of
this year and if you guys want to see
the camera comparison you'll want to do
that if you guys want to see the
previous camera comparison the unbiased
blind one
really fun to watch we have it right
over there thank you guys for watching
it's been max
and i will see you in the next video